la plupart de ces journées commencent
par un rituel
le polo dès que j'ai un peu de temps je
m'entraîne je joue c'est vraiment mon
passe temps favori j'aime ça une petite
demi heure à faire galoper son pur-sang
dans les jardins du palais de rares
moments de détente carnard under singh
n'a pas de temps à perdre
et il passe ses journées à se déplacer
d'hôtel en hôtel d'anciens palais que la
famille a réaménagé pour accueillir les
touristes
[Musique]
ce jour là il se rend à 200km de jaïpur
dans un ancien palais d'été de maharaja
c'est aujourd'hui un hôtel de charme
d'une vingtaine de chambres nar enders
vérifie lui même la comptabilité le
maharadja est devenu businessman un peu
malgré lui vous avez payé les salaires
de janvier en espèces oui en espèces
monsieur c'est quelque chose de nouveau
pour vous business man je sais mais
quand on veut se lancer dans les
affaires il faut apprendre pour réussir
[Applaudissements]
narrateur poussent parfois le
professionnalisme jusqu'à accueillir lui
même les touristes
[Musique]
après cinq heures de car ce groupe de
saint-etienne ne s'attendait pas à
pareil honneur
madame sûr que je vous présente heures
marana rendering qui marie avec les
princesses 2g pour donc il vous souhaite
la bienvenue
merci beaucoup d'être venu ici
et bienvenue à tous j'espère que vous
allez apprécier votre séjour au
rajasthan le rajasthan
c'est la destination à la mode en inde
l'an dernier trois millions et demi de
visiteurs sont venus découvrir ses
charmes mais aussi son exotisme
[Musique]
des touristes venus des quatre coins du
monde qui se laisse volontiers tenter
par une balade à dos d'éléphant au monde
par deux
même si c'est un peu comme sur une
autoroute d'avoir le mal de mer vous
pensez cannibale a franchi les alpes
avec à dos d'éléphant pour sa part d'une
partie de plaisir
[Musique]
comme il se doit certains profitent du
filon toutes les russes sont autorisés
pour alléger le porte-monnaie du
touriste
impossible par exemple de repartir sans
sa photo souvenir
[Musique]
une belle promenade vous avez déjà le
foot au ritz était violée comment cette
façon combien ça coûte un vrai que toi
sur ce marché
j'ai commis une faute au sol sans répit
les quêtes sont pile et ken sont
horribles aux jeunes horrible
négociateurs